okay thank you for being here uh
so i'm an independent uh
development architect i'm mostly doing
security stuff when my kids ask what i
do at work i say
that i build login buttons
uh and behind those login buttons
there's usually a sample to open a
deconnect or a mix of them or well
complicated stuff
but i do like security and i've always
liked security since i started coding
more than 30 years ago
so today we are going to look at os top
10 and see how that
how asp.net core stands up to those
threats
and to be honest this version of os top
10 i'm
basing this talk on is not the latest
one
uh this is kind of a bonus talk where
they asked yesterday if there were
anyone that had had extra talks to fill
i'm just losing the schedule so i bring
up one and obviously someone released a
new over as top 10 version since i
created this talk
but still the asp.net core mechanism are
the same
so let's get started
so why asp.net core well a full repeats
mistakes smart personally learns from
their mistakes and wise person learns
from others mistakes so that's why i
want to use ervos protein because that's
a top list of other people's mistakes
and we can learn from them
so let's see
how is a split on that core standing up
to
the threats in er was top 10
the number one
on this version of roster 10 is
injection
so what is
an injection attack well consider
webshop where we do have
a possibility to view orders
site.com order question mark id equals
17.
this would typically be used in a sql
query in this way
that
the program takes whatever is after that
parameter and put it into the template
here and creates a sql statement that is
run on the sql server
and an injection attack well consider if
i entered this order number
when trying to access the site
it's still a valid order number but i
also added drop table orders
so the program will happily do what it
should it will take this part
put it there and create this sql
statement and if this sql statement is
executed to the database or the webshop
i guess the web shop will not be very
healthy afterwards what do you think
so
let's have a look at how
asp.net core handles the risk of
injections
it doesn't
because what is the default
database accessing you when using
asp.net nowadays is link language
integrated query there is no string
manipulation anymore
we are simply
using a strongly typed representation of
the query and then we have an engine
behind a hardened engine that creates
the actual sql statements that are run
and that hardened engine of course use
correct parameterized queries and this
is something unlike with asp.net core
they have secure practices so go with
the stream follow the stream use the
main tools it will be secure in most
ways
then of course there are
exceptions if you for example are using
dapper
it's a popular lightweight orm with net
it's fast
it allows you to you write your sql
queries directly then you of course need
to be careful to not open up for
injection attacks but on the other hand
i think that the choice of using
dapper is probably
something that is uh
not what
uh is a conscious decision probably and
with that conscious decision i hope
comes
uh awareness of the risks of using sql
strings
so
let's move on
to broken authentication this is my
favorite i'm doing authentication and
login buttons most of my time the time
so when we have authentication when we
go to website and log on we have
something like this uh username password
we hit the login button we send that
over to the server the server valid is
that
and then since http is a stateless the
next time
my client sends
a request to that server the server goes
like
who are you
and how did you find me
so what do we mechanism do we typically
use to
um
to pre preserve state or represent the
session i have a special price what is
the technology we are using
cookie you want cookies
of course we give it a cookie and the
server is happy
now i want you to have that face because
you also get cookies
um
so let's see at an example on how
uh another
login method might look like and this is
actually fun because i
did create this example sometime back
and
i meant to put in some issues in this
i meant to put in like two or three
issues i've used this as a number of
conferences and now the list is up to
six different issues people have found
in this code
let me see if you can find a seventh i
don't know if there is a seventh issue
here or not
so okay what's wrong
this is something i might have written
like 25 years ago to the best of my
ability it's wrong what's wrong with
this
sql injection right we have sql
injection here
uh
what do we have more
yes to store the username uh right away
in the cookie uh
so i i have no
i really just put current user username
so what if the uh anyone
just modifies the cookie they would you
could create you know set your own
cookie and say your admin
so it's horrible yeah what more
yeah there's no kind of lockout or
anything we can just
try whatever
as many times as possible no protection
against that
what about the password validation is
this a good way to validate passwords
with the in a database
they should be sorted and hashed right
we're just restoring them obviously in
clear
text um
so we have a couple more on my list
still known you
no no lockout yep
and
no password requirements yeah that's
actually or
um this wouldn't be where we would put
in password requirements because this is
when we log in and validate the password
so it's not the set password
method where we set it
there's a simple logic flaw
if you follow the code because what
would happen if you enter the wrong
password
still logs you in exactly
there's no return or anything here it
shakes if results not has rose but then
it sets the cookie unconditionally at
the end
either way
that was not intentional um
and then there's something
when doing cookies an authentication
cookie we should be a bit more careful
about our cookie what should we mature
about cookies
same side and also http only we should
be strict about so much reviews on the
cookies so this is a brilliant example
on how to not write the login method
oh yes it actually says http post
uh okay might be
you usually when you set
that kind of requirement it should be
posted it will require a post but yeah
if that's true it's it's bad as well
because
you're in that way yeah okay
that's new okay there's a new thing you
deserve the second package of cookies
for that
here you are
uh now i got it so yeah no guard that
the username and password really came
from the
body that's right
okay so
well
what should we do
uh we shouldn't do this ourselves we
should use between components to do
like asp.net identity so let's look at
how
uh authentication works in asp.net core
and first look at what a speed on the
asp.net core pipeline works
it's the official name is a chain of
responsibility pattern it's one of the
original design patterns in the gang of
four books from 94 something 1994.
i usually refer to it as a blame game
it means that
the first middleware the static files
middleware i get the chance to handle
the request
if it
doesn't know it blames the next one the
authentication middleware and so on and
at the end of the chain there's also
always a hardcover 404 middleware that
just says 404
doesn't exist and returns
so
instead of using that crappy login
method from the last slide
we should use asp.net identity which is
a built-in library
i can have some
opinions about the design but it's not
insecure
asp.net identity would validate the
would validate the username and password
against
the
[Music]
storage whatever and then
set an app cookie
and on the subsequent request when a
subsequent request comes in the
authentication middleware will check is
there a cookie set okay and let's test
the user
uh property on the http context so
subsequent like the
middleware in the pipeline such as the
msc
handler or milwaukee will be able to
just access user and that will be the
login session
but there's one drawback with this and
that is when i whenever i come to a site
that looks like this i said oh no
let's bring out the password manager
let's create another password let's try
to remember this
this is not what people accept nowadays
what people ex
[Music]
expect
is that they should use their favorite
social network or external login
provider right
or in corporate setup you want single
sign on with your corporate account
and this is where asp.net identity has a
really good data model because
they have the idea that one user can
have multiple logins so there is an
identity your user identity in the
application that is connected or mapped
to a number of
login methods one or more
so back to our chain of responsibility
sorry blame game and see how this would
work
if i on that login page would hit sign
in with google
that would trigger a call to the
external authentication handler for
google
that will do the redirect out to google
where google does their authentication
thingy
and then they
post or redirects a result back
that is caught by the authentication
hand
authentication middleware
that
routes the
incoming response to the google
authentication handler
the google authentication handler
will in a typical setup preserve that at
in something called an external cookie
so we have two different cookie schemes
in a typical setup
we do not want to sign the user in to
our application with the identity we got
from google directly
we want to preserve that identity we got
from google
and then
we want to redirect them to somewhere in
our application where we can see is this
a user that is mapped to an existing
account or is it a new user do we want
to grab some information we got from
google and stored in our database kind
of
kind of thing that is typically done in
an external callback method
and the external callback method calls
into asp.net identity to
look up
this google identity we just
got here is that mapped to some a user
in our system and if it is
it calls to the app cookie to set that
preserve that user identity for
subsequent requests
and on the subsequent request we simply
use the app cookie and all of these
complex
things are hidden
um
one might ask why do we do all of this
but well this gives us an opportunity to
show ui
while we hang on to the google identity
we got from google
and we're still trying to figure out if
this is linked to something where we
might want to bring the users through a
license acceptance screen or anything a
workflow before actually letting them
into our application
some a bit complex maybe but powerful
so more about
authentication
back in the days we had web apps and we
had browsers and we used cookies and
everyone was happy
then we added more powerful javascript
applications we're writing entire client
applications that are running in the
browser nowadays
and those are typically calling a rest
api
and if this had been
four or five four years ago
i would now have started on a long
explanation why
the javascript app should be an open id
connect client and why it should use
an oauth 2 beer token to call the rest
api to mitigate sea surf attacks etc etc
but it turns out that no
that was
a dead end
design wise the up-to-date
recommendation is to stick to your
cookies
and use cookies even for javascript
applications
and in case your javascript apple app
needs to call multiple
apis it should do that through
what is called a back-end for front-end
so the javascript app should just call
api endpoints on its own domain
and then that that back-end can relay to
other services
so that's the authentication any
questions on the authentication block
okay let's move on to number three on
the obos top 10 list sensitive data
exposure
this is really about
how data is stored and
there are a couple of mechanisms in
asp.net core to mitigate this one is in
asp.net identity core we mentioned that
storing the
passwords in plain text as my silly
login method
did was wrong
asp.net identity core used nist approved
pbkdf2
algorithm hmx shot 256 with 10 000
iterations as default
is configurable if you want to have more
iterations
we do have a required http as a tribute
to force
particular to force uh some controllers
uh to use https but i think that is
actually already deprecated
would you run anything on plane http
anymore
nope just use https everywhere
then we have
a piece that you've all used in if
you're
net developers
many times probably without knowing
about it is the data protector
so the data protector is a wrapper
around low-level encryption primitives
that is really simple to use you can
take a data protector
take source string hello world put it
through a data protector you get some
gibberish back
and you can then unprotect it and get
hello world back
so why is this important well
uh the data protection there is accessed
by the way uh by using a data protection
provider is a
service that you can inject into you get
injection from the da system and then
you need to create a specific data
protector with a purpose and i'll just
show you why
in the next slide to use it
dp.protect hello world or unprotect the
protected data
and this is the elegance elegance really
of the data protector it's simple to use
behind this
we have key management key rotation
proper encryption proper signing with
strong algorithm correct uses of aes
with initialization vectors all of that
that it's just so simple to get wrong so
i like this abstraction
it's encryption that like it should be
just hand in something a simple method
method
where is it used well
one example is the authentication
cookies
it's really a claims identity that is
just run through the data protector and
put in the cookie
that's what's in the asp.net
application cookie
and then i mentioned we had to specify
purpose and why that consider if i have
both using data protector with the
session cookies and i also have
in my application i have a wizard where
i do some
really expensive validation of the data
in one step
and i want to carry that on in hidden
input fields
and the next time i'm using that data i
just want to trust it without having to
revalidate i could use the data
protector to do that so i can run the
complex validation when someone enters
the data
put the validated data through data
protector and let it be carried on as a
hidden input field for the rest of the
wizard
now
consider what if i
enter some data
in that wizard
that
is like user anders royal admin
i and then i use that to swap with the
cookie
so i don't have the encryption key i
cannot create encrypted just create
encrypted values but i could piggyback
on the functionality that i can input
information in the wizard that is run
through the data protector and then i
can take that encrypted data and put it
in the cookie
well this is why your purpose
this is because the reason that we need
to specify purpose is that we should not
be able to take something that was
generated by the data potential for one
purpose and abused it for a different
purpose
one thing to mention also with data
protection is that when we are running
in a modern environment which is load
balanced
we need to make sure that the data
protection keys are
handled in a way if we're on multiple
servers that they share the same data
protection keys and app identifiers
otherwise they will not be able to
recognize cookies
if a cookie is issued by one node in the
cluster and the subsequent request is
processed by another node in the cluster
they must be a matching keys if you are
running on azure
azure web apps just handles this out of
the box but with aws for example there's
some configuration you need to do to
ensure the data protection works across
the nodes in the cluster
let's move on to number four xml
external entities
you remember xml that's the old version
of json where we had angle brackets
and where we could do all weird kind of
stuff with dtds etc
uh so so this is an interesting
example of where xml is powerful but a
bit too powerful
what this does is to say that we do this
is a dangerous document with the
dtd
it actually resolves this
to
uh when it resolves uh
this entity it will actually call out to
somewhere else
and it will do that
uh at that point i can return another
entity which contains some stuff
and in the end
i could cause the exit just loading an
xml document
to actually submit the etc password wd
file to the remote attacker so consider
if i just upload or send in a simple xml
file to an api
if they have
have external entity processing enabled
i could actually steal the password
database of that system or use a
database of the system
so what need to be done when running an
asp.net core
to protect against this kind of attacks
well once more section is attention and
left blank because this these behaviors
are disabled by default in a bit of net
core
number five on the list broken access
control
this is also relates to direct object
reference
which is another item on the list i was
blisp
so
what if i click this link
it probably says shopping.com order and
then an id
if i just modify that url
enter 47
is that link properly protected it's not
uncommon to see that people are showing
that you're just shown the list of your
own orders
but
they forgot to protect the actual end
point
um and this is an area where i think
asp.net core is is so much better than
previous versions of asp.net because
previous versions of asp.net they had
the authorized attribute anyone has been
using that
yeah
and you could also do roles
the problem with this is that if it is a
customer that is only allowed to view
their own orders
this doesn't help
authorized with roles was under the
assumption that either you're allowed to
execute a method with any kind of
parameters or you're not allowed to
access the method at all
with asp.net core we do have more
powerful policies
that we should use and why that well
because you do define the policy
somewhere else and now we do not have
the
knowledge that there is a role
or claim
um or type role that has the value admin
we centralize that knowledge to
one place in the application
and we can do a lot more things than
just evaluate on the role
we can actually here we can actually run
any kind of curves there
and implement any kind of complex access
rules
policies are really powerful
this is a simple way to just inline
define a policy but there is a more
powerful way where we have policy that
represents by requirements requirements
or objects carrying parameters
and then we have handlers that verifies
requirements
in this example we could
have a generic minimum age handler
that can validate any age
and the over 18 policy
puts in the
requirement with a par meter of 18.
that looks a bit ridiculous let's take a
more complex read journal medical
records
we might have multiple requirements to
read medical record one is that in
sweden list there's a rule you need to
have a smart card login
or strong authentication mechanisms to
be able to read medical records that can
be done by a
medical handler
we can also put in another requirement
to say that you can only read medical
records of someone where you have a
patient relationship the doctor cannot
go in and read any medical record for
anyone on the hospital they are just
allowed to do that for their own
patients
that can be handled by an app
a handler that checks the
booking system to see if this doctor has
an appointment booked with that patient
it could also be done by hand but we can
also have another handler that says is
this doctor in the emergency room if
this was someone coming in by ambulance
there's probably not an appointment
because people did not plan to go have
an accident and go in by ambulance
uh an advantage here is that the
handlers are full-blown services
registered with the di system so you can
access databases
any service anything
so it's really powerful
but is also quite complex so i would say
that
it's good to know that this story exists
and that there is a powerful
authorization concept but if you can
stick to the simple in-line policies do
that and
move on to the more powerful systems
when you need it
but this morse to authorization were not
yet done they did a lot of improvements
let's get back to our order here
that we said we couldn't handle that
with a simple authorized attribute
because
we
we cannot we don't know if a customer is
allowed to
view order 42
right we cannot tell that right away we
need to check the order and see if the
current user is actually the customer to
that particular order right
that's called resource-based
authorization
so
i can first load the order object from
the database or storage wherever i have
it and then i can have a policy where i
submit
i submit the order retrieved from the
database
let's see here laser pointer i include
the order as a parameter
when evaluating the policy
so what does the policy look like
well the policy
is part of ad authorization in the
services registration you would
obviously move this to a separate file
if you have complex policies but
let's just do it in line here we add a
policy show order the policy
requires searching and this is my
favorite
require researching means
run this expression over here or this
method over here and see if it returned
in short it returns true that's the
escape hatch out of that horrible or not
horrible but that complex requirement
handler thing you can just require a
searching
so the policy here
if a user is allowed to show an order is
that if the user is enrolled employee
or
we the owner of the order is the current
user
then we allow the user to view the order
resource-based authorization
solves one of the problems
another problem with authorization is
the mismatch that sometimes happened do
you know when when you have that edit
button visible
you do a lot of changes and then you hit
save just to say access denied
that is just awkward ux
to work around that we can inject the
authorization service into views
and actually use
the same policy this policy we're using
when the order is saved
exactly the same policy can be used to
decide whether to render the edit button
or not
when doing mvc
and this is something i really like that
we can do it in
in one place
so
the order to summarize on authorization
uh we do have the authorized attribute
which is the very basic thing that just
requires the user to be logged in
don't use roles use policies
and we do have the policy requirement
handler set up
that is powerful but often overkill
resource-based authorization which i
think is a huge improvement
that you can now
first load the resource
in a controlled manner i mean i've seen
all sort of strange things where
they mandated
an application mandated that all urls
contains a specific parameter so they
could have a handcrafted
attribute that looks at that parameter
and it's just awkward this is so much
more
powerful and natural
we have used
the view based authorization
uh so
finally a powerful authorization
framework
question authorization in asp.net core
uh
let's go back to where we're using it
it's it's simply in in this method
uh is it me they're having sound on
let's
no i thought it was muted uh so uh
when we did sorry i just need to i
thought i had
mute
um
this is just an exterior so that really
here what you would have is that
before you do load it from your normal
data store without doing any validation
you receive from the database or
anything and once you've retrieved it
you call this block of code so i simply
omitted the resource loading
you have to have it in your code and
you're moving the authorization from an
attribute and into the actual body of
the controller or whatever method does
it so it's an imperative
way to call the authorization service
you have
still have the attribute option if that
is enough which is often the more simple
way but in some cases you need to do
some work and then check authorization
by calling the authorization service
directly
was there more questions
okay let's move on
skimming through here and
security misconfiguration
this is about
adding services you know way back when
things just added everything that you
could potentially need and you had even
to go to the machine to config to see
hidden http modules that were all
preloaded into any application running
on the system
those were the days and if one of those
had an issue
you had problems and you might even not
be aware that it was in the material
config
asp.net core takes the
uh
another approach it just does whatever
you map into the pipeline
if you're not adding new static files
it won't
even serve static files from anywhere on
the file system
if you want to use identity you need to
add it and this opt-in method really
guards against security misconfiguration
number seven on the list cross-site
scripting
what is it consider we have a simple
rating form
if i leave a comment
three does anyone ever leave in three
stars in rating form have you seen that
people leave one
this is this is crap or five this is
brilliant they never leave a number
three
um
but i would do works but nothing fancy
because what i do want to put in there
here is a script
evil.comcookie.js
script tag because i want this review
comment to be published on the site for
subsequent visitors to the site
and then my hope is that
it will actually render the script tag
as a tag
and mainly
traditionally
to guard against cross-site
scripting there was really a burden on
the developer
remember to always html escape all
content you put out if you forgot that
in one single place in your application
you could have cross-eyed scripting
vulnerabilities
what about asp.net core let's see
let's just put out a simple
script
as a string
in a razor
what will it do
well it will actually display this
because razer html escapes it escapes
anything by default
if you actually want to prove that
pre-formatted html you need to
tell a razer that this is indeed already
an html string please do not escape it
and it's once more
secure by default
if we forget this gate if we forget
about it what would happen is that our
html
will be escaped and the tags visible to
the user and that is something you find
in the tests or find
just when you run it the first time
but if you forgot
html escape it where you should have
done it
then
it can pass through the tests
yep
the built-in functionalities is that
either
you run it through full escape and and
then then
uh anything will be escaped and put out
as is or that
you say that this is pre-formatted html
string i want exactly this html string
to be put out
yeah because you should never really put
out a html that
came from user input
not that i'm aware of for example if you
if you allow them to people to enter
html that could be
published no nothing built in that i'm
aware of
so let's move to number eight on the
list insecurity serialization
so
what is that well consider there is a
class in the dot net framework that
uh is called temp file collection
what temp file collection does the idea
with the temp file collection is that
you create a number of
um
you create now
create a temp temporary files during
some operation and you want
automatic cleanup
so when the temp file collection object
is destroyed it deletes all the files
it's kept track of
that's handy right
what if i can send in a json object
that gets deserialized into a temp file
collection instance
and i send in
that
arbitrary file names that i know are
critical to a windows system
then when that object is destroyed it
would delete those files
and here is something that is actually
one one way
the only
place in this presentation where i have
this red box to be careful
and that is
if you ever do
using the json serializer if you ever
switch on type name handling all you are
vulnerable never ever
deserialize untrusted data
with
allowing it to deserialize into any
or
any class
so deserialization
there are still dangers here and you
need to keep track of if there's trusted
data or untrusted data when running it
through decentralization
but for example the data protector
if you
serialize data and run it through the
data protector when you're unprotected
you can be sure it's your data and it's
secure to just deserialize it
and number nine
uh on this version of evostrep10 using
components with known vulnerabilities
who would do that
well of course we keep track of our
components do we
it was easier way
way back windows update saved us with
the net framework
uh and it's still
that if you're running the.net framework
it's the responsibility of the windows
system administrator or to run it
but it and also if you're relying on the
shard.net core or dotnet is nowadays
named
it's also the system but for
if we are packaging
and this redistribution the the net
libraries with our application we are
responsible for also updating that
but the same with all other components
what about all those new get packages
and this is something that
um
i think that now we have tooling there
was a talk previously
today that i i couldn't attend about the
github
how github helps
and github warns you if you have code
that references and you get packages
with known vulnerabilities but still you
need to keep track of that you need to
update them
um and this is really when when our
ecosystem is expanding with more
components third-party components
you need to have a strategy to
monitor all of them to see if there are
security vulnerabilities and
update and redeploy if that happens
and this is really nothing that asp.net
core as a development environment or web
framework can help with
number 10 finally instead of no not
finally we i have a bonus uh
number 10 uh insufficient logging
monitoring
well
i think the built-in logging abilities
of asp.net core is great
we have an eye logger that can be
injected everywhere we have structured
logging
which means that tools like
application insights can
help us search easier for parameters and
known parameters and there are a lot of
good tooling out there just use it
that was all on that version was it was
part 10 but there's one more that i
think is so important i want to mention
it and that's cross-site request forgery
you remember the cookies
so uh to you
who are lucky to have a bunch of cookies
for later
i can tell you they are delicious
but i also want to warn you they are bad
for your health in if you eat too many
of them
when we talk about
uh computer cookies or web cookies they
are simple because they are auto
transmitted by they are bad because they
are auto transmitted
let me tell you a story about what
happened some years
ago this is a 6-0
modem adsl mode and i had one it was
very common there were a few hundred
thousand i think sweden distributed by
one of the large operators
it had a page where you could just all
the dns settings and if you enter the
information there it would be sent to
some action that's stored
so one day in a
net online form i got a request from a
security researcher saying hey
do i know anyone that has one of these
modems
and i said um yes i do
and he said oh great please can go to
this link
no no no not at all suspicious so so
okay um
well i did
and i got a page of kittens
the evil kittens
of course i
the browser devtools what is it on this
well what happened was that there was an
iframe hidden iframe on this page with a
hidden form
that
say
the mimic the dns settings
and
send that to the static ip address of my
modem
and it changed dns server so suddenly i
was not using the right in a service i
was using dns servers all devices on my
home network we're now using the dns
servers of the attacker
just by me going to
a simple page viewing
some cute kittens
the problem here is cross-site request
forgery so the evil kittens were able to
post to the modem or rather the modem
accepted
settings coming from the evil kittens
they shouldn't
to avoid this
anything that accepts
posted data should
remember to create a token containing a
random component preferably tied to the
current users encrypt and sign it store
that token in a form field and store the
same token in a cookie and when there is
a post
back to your system
verify that the tokens are actual equal
check the signature and decrypt them
and validate it's still the same user
signed on
and to do all of that in asp.net core
call val remember add validate and
afford your token
and that is actually
that the default in asp.net core is that
whenever you're using
a form entry a form where the the
asp.something
attributes
the form tag helper kicks in and the
form tag helper
ensures that the cookie is created if it
doesn't exist and it ensures the hidden
form fill is generated so you actually
kind of need to opt out of that behavior
to not have the
request verification
uh
in hidden input field in a form jade
narrated by
razer
and then you add validate and afford
your token on on the methods
or you can add it as a global filter
then same site restrictions for cookies
helps a lot because if your cook session
cookies are
with the same size strict
that would have saved us from the evil
kittens
on the other hand i usually think about
that we have like 98 percent i think of
users now use browsers that are
compatible with
the modern cookie restrictions and
that are following the same site
rules
the problem is who are those two percent
that have legacy browsers
are there security aware people are
there are those typically people that
uh
know how to see a phishing mail or
something no
those two percent running the legacy
browsers are typically
people that are not that tech savvy and
they are typically running an older
device that is unpatched so i think
that even though we have same side that
is a great tool i think still think we
should for a few more years carry on
having anti-forgery
validation or
protection this is actually removed from
our top 10 since a couple of revisions
because
the
it's not seen as a problem in the wild
but that is thanks to what asp.net core
now the frameworks do to protect against
this
so that was the bonus
to summarize
aspen.net core is mostly secure by
default
we have the blame game sorry middleweb
pipeline
that is good to just understand that it
exists and how it relates to
authentication that authentication
happens as part of the pipeline
and typically i forgot to mention that
static files are served before
authentication is checked
so
the static files
have no protection at all in a standard
setup
and
authorization with the policies
a brand new
way more
flexible and powerful authorization
framework
data protection that is a key component
behind the scenes
and it's something you might need to
configure
in a
hosting environment
and afford your token cross-site request
forgery
well it's a built-in protection that is
really smart but you need to enable it
and make sure it runs
so that's all i had for asp.net core
meets it was top 10 and
my uh views on this is that i think
asp.net core has a really great and
solid security foundation
to tackle the
uh most common uh scenarios
any more questions
i can go back to the summer if you
wanted to be here
yes there might be cases where it re
falsely rejects data
uh very few but i've seen people for
example running very high volume
websites
and having data that is not
sensitive
and uh
they got rejections and they say we are
losing customers over it
um
there's also scenarios that if you
if you load a form
and then for example you are get signed
out when the form is still open your
session expires
that then the
middleware will reject it or handler
will reject it
because it is tied to the current user
and that is a in many ways a protection
so that
if you hit save you see i'm logged in as
anders and i hit save i should be sure
that i'm actually saving the data to my
account and not yours account your
account if you if you somehow have evil
kittens that i've watched that somehow
tr used other vulnerabilities to
cause my session to get signed out from
my account and signed into your account
i don't want my sensitive database to be
saved to your account
so there are some
occasions where there might be drawbacks
but
usually not
yes
is there a way to
configure
authentication before the
static files or for specifics
yes
absolutely uh it is depending on the
order in the startup file where you have
this app dot use static files app.use
authentication just put you use
authentication before
static files then that will ensure that
you know who the user is but then you
also need to configure the static file
middleware to have some authorization
rules
because by default the aesthetic file
middleware
just serves as files to anyone uh i'm
sure it can be done but i don't know how
you can so
there's a lot
any more questions
okay
i think that's it for and that wraps the
first day of the conference and uh it's
over to the final session the
party you for attending